9h30 dans un hôtel du centre ville
d'orléans les panthères du fleury loiret
handball arrivent les unes après les
autres
le rituel d'une journée de match le
premier à domicile en ligue des
champions la plus prestigieuse des
coupes d'europe
un événement pour beaucoup sauf pour le
club pour nous voilà la première c'était
la semaine dernière et j'espère très
sincèrement qu'on va être capable de
laisser les émotions de côté parce que
la semaine dernière je sens que sa fin
on a senti que ça nous apporter un peu
préjudice dans la gestion de notre match
donc donc j'espère qu'aujourd'hui
voilà plein feu c'est fini les émotions
les laisse de côté et on fait un match
plein se préparer au mieux pour sortir
le match qu'il faut comme le veut la
tradition les filles vont prendre un bol
d'air une balade en bord de loire
dernier moment de détente avant d'entrer
vraiment dans le vif du sujet sans
fermer peu à peu dans sa bulle
10h lors de la causerie la dernière
réunion entre le coach et ses joueuses
quelques rappelle quelques consignes
mathématiquement le match nul en
allemagne la semaine dernière est une
bonne chose mais face aux hongroises
il faudra être encore plus agressif une
fois un match beaucoup plus linéaire
parce que ft cca c'est un ton au dessus
une sera-t-on au dessus après un bon ton
grain bon ton nom c'est plus est plus
dense physiquement c'est assez
expérimenté aussi voilà
ça des fonds très très dur très très dur
donc ça va être un gros combat cet après
midi à 15 heures 15 les panthères en
mission pas impossible
le compte à rebours est lancé